[Music]
this week we've got dubstep protection
our ap Homme neige
an epic battle alright be god I'm bad
too the script protection oh I know what
it is your ears
Skrillex mosquito yeah okay hi he's
coming out with mosquitos and as you
think he's branding all the mosquitoes
that's like the next level marketing
there yeah they're injecting it with
Skrillex so then they're all gonna when
they fly on the I don't know they're
doing some [ __ ] where they can control
it and I can't [ __ ] spaces I was
believable I didn't believe that [ __ ]
for one second you sound like you've
been grilled by the cops they say like
they follow a solar pattern there's a
certain thing that they do stupid you
couldn't follow along no I thought you
were gonna say something like you know
those drones that they synchronized to
do yeah that's what I was trying to get
it that's how it was going but I started
laughing so good you're so bad at it you
remind me of a little kid that had a
secret you're like it was so quiet so
many mosquitoes I understand though
because some of these articles are so
[ __ ] ridiculous like you just don't
know sometimes yeah this one's good
though so there's been this recent
scientific study the science they found
out that when you play Skrillex
specifically his song called scary
monsters and nice sprites that song
if the mosquitoes stop biting people and
they stop mating music high and low
frequency changes in the song there's a
dollar that's the MA Oh
no [ __ ] mosquitoes I'm gonna play this
[ __ ] when I go to chop a play I do but
you still like animals period but I mean
you know I mean I kill them a lot yeah
they have no equal first oh we don't
need them for anyway the only animal I
read disease
how have they survived this long because
all they do
oh they could just butter lady they're
like Satan every mosquito died in
nothing would change by them tie
Skrillex actually a lot of these really
people wouldn't die anymore anyways from
that [ __ ] dude do you like malaria and
[ __ ] and die what the [ __ ] what's now
that what true yeah similary important
yeah but I decided I just don't hear
about it out here is there effects I
want yeah but you're talking about
positive change right now bigot of
change like that be was gonna happen no
yeah I was talking about just a team
anyway I'll play you a little part of
that song so you guys can hear this song
all the time when I go to the tulu or
Taiwan
this song was so big when it came a
little sounds like every song that I've
heard he pioneered it though everyone
copies him oh I see this that make sense
then cuz some fun loungy eating and
stuff like this right this is when you
work out but this that's what I said I
hate you like like subscribe trance
music I don't like any of that [ __ ] but
not dubstep but anyway that's the part
of the song that's the song that
everybody [ __ ] cuts they're real -
does it matter like how high or how low
it is for as long as it's playing period
well it's just so it said an insect's
low frequency vibrations facilitate
sexual interactions whereas noise
disrupts the perception of signals from
conspecifics
so the members of the same species and
hopes so they're saying that because
it's like when you play this they're not
able to have that communication Oh cuz
there's so much like things going on
yeah but the offset is that you have to
listen to that [ __ ] I wonder if it's
like any other dubstep song how do they
find this out who was doing the research
on that hoe like cosplay music for
mosquitoes like you know look at that
actually there's a lot of scientists
like trying to figure out mosquitoes how
to like stop the proper like good for
their population to continue to grow and
like help humans and ship I'm not
getting bit like they'd recently
discovered that by doing some gene
editing they well if they found like the
sort of birth control for mosquitoes
where if they do this gene editing thing
they turn off this one thing that once
they lay eggs the egg isn't viable for
the mosquitoes just survive and then
they died perfect cuz we don't need that
[ __ ]
but mosquito let's do that I like that
[ __ ] with skleros um in Mexico like
where I'm from there's like hella
mosquitoes cuz it's like super like drop
yeah like it's wet over there um and
over there my Diaz she always tells me
she's like okay you bring me bath and
body work spray because they use that to
like not get bit by my skin no no it
makes it go away
you know yeah they tend I don't wear
anything sweet she literally but she's
like oh yeah we were she calls her by
she knows she's like oh missing body
yeah yeah and so then that she puts it
on and then they don't might you ever
get no I tried it we even get big and
there later off is all that over there
yeah yeah I don't know why I don't know
maybe it was it a specific one literally
any one of them like it could be anyone
from Bath and Body Works I don't know if
she's trying with Victoria's Secret but
I mean they're from the same company
Victoria's Secret Owens Bath and Body
Works so I don't know I don't know that
either it's - I can pay my credit card
bill Victoria Secret or bath and body
work oh yeah no more you know they got
the best candles man they do turn it on
yesterday and I was like which one so
every well they change the name recently
but every fall through Christmas they
had the same scented candle it's like
this yellow one I forgot what the
original name was but they changed the
name recently but it's like holiday and
citrus is what it's called now but it's
bomb that's my [ __ ] dude it makes it
it's not sexy in there
I like that didn't I always [ __ ] just
she had a great collection of candles
too well really see yeah huh you have
the app there's a candle zap I'm that
dude I'm a lady I have a whole video on
this to y'all y'all need to get on it
so the candles that you would normally
get for 2450 with the app like they
always have sells like not in between
big holidays you know because that's
like when it's fast for them like when
it's slower when they're literally be
like $10 off the candle and then if you
spend $30 you get $10 off so you like
two candles and you get them each for
like they got that during the holiday
she knows you get like these so they're
about like 24 50 each you can get them
for like 10 to 12 bucks I stock up yes
dude it's not bomb usually crazy candles
aren't they for old people no they're
for people who like there's how are you
stupid
I put candles on
you stupid about that sex is always a
candle that's cute dude that's the
signal this look nice in the house you
guys were [ __ ] my good smell mate all
right it smells like gardenia a lot of
them but because I love them so much and
you don't want to play no mono okay know
when you have like that I wanna know
what you have to think about that so one
day you're gonna die so you need your
house smelling nice now she's gonna get
buried with it you don't know very very
well buried no you don't want that you
want to enjoy it but I'm the same way as
tough while of tissue paper so much so
after I shouldn't even wipe I just leave
it there I don't want to use it all we
do have a bidet is using the water no
I'm not I love the bidet so much I don't
want to use it but I love my toilet
paper
oh yeah the weakens guys remember I
forgot oh okay
so Elon Musk recently tweeted out his
RIPTA Rhomb a song by his record company
called emo G records must be fun he's a
funny people he don't give a [ __ ] you
know what I recently discovered so when
he did the announcement for model white
you know the new why are you so sexy you
just discovered it when he was talking
about it is when I'm figuring it out
because I didn't I didn't put it
together before you know said a while
ago though that that's what it cuz I
couldn't get the e because Ford or
something was trying to sue him yeah so
he has a Model S he has a model 3 has a
Model X and a mano y when you put it
together it's about sex
oh that's cute I know and I found out it
wouldn't he was talking about it for the
model wife I was like [ __ ] how did
you know how did you find out was he
saying it he said it he explained the
thing the whole thing like so Model S
was because they were making a sedan so
S stands for oh yeah and then I did the
X and then he was like oh there before
me we supposed sucks
ands up but then he couldn't do eat
something he did I mean yeah he did the
three mm-hmm that's tired he tweeted
this out emoji records in the SoundCloud
link or AP Harambee that's it tight and
then he said I'm disappointed that
label says wow this is a little clip of
that song we are wait Harambee passed
away killed him right the gorillas need
16 they killed him why because of the
kid yeah okay okay I'm caught up
I'm caught up no [ __ ] is going on over
there tonight
that was a while don't it literally did
a song about it come on in May 2016
that's why in the seventeen-year-old
gorilla and Cincinnati Zoo was shot
because a little boy are they into his
enclosure yeah yeah yes that little kid
was being dragged that [ __ ] was
hilarious but that wasn't even bad she
was taking care of that kid I don't know
he was kind of dragging his face against
the rocks
that's the kid's father he grabbed his
ankle it was like Jesus baby
to New Guinea Michelle
like a song me and Joey he's living the
life that I want to live to have
unlimited amount of money to do whatever
the fuss you want and it doesn't matter
if it fails or succeeds yeah I know what
would you do I would I would open up
with jujitsu school even though I don't
know any GU that I would teach a class
for about a week and then send them out
into the world that's tight
I know that is kind of boring that's a
fun huh that's just the basic stuff
though what are you starting with that
your basic [ __ ] giggle though it's like
somebody actually signed up to learn
jujitsu and then they say sign up for
what we're gonna teach them nothing it
just makes me laugh you know that's just
the first thing I don't know I don't I
don't have a lot of big dreams but I
have a lot of stuff that makes me give I
don't have a lot of big dreams I don't
I just want to suck dick for money
huzzah my billion I was like hella
videos back they're gonna be like what
no don't no no no that's my life goal
bubs your life that's Joe's like I'm
sure I like all two if you go on
Craigslist you'll find someone up yeah
but those numbers are too low though
girl I'm sure you could get it up there
what was that what's the highest number
you think only give me these lips are
luscious by the way I think see like if
we're talking about a guy who's
desperate was never left this house in
like 20 years
dig that's gonna pay you know what I
mean like a good-looking guys I'm gonna
be like ow pay money like you could pay
a good-looking girl but I mean Katya you
know or a guy that's tired of ladies and
wants to try some new [ __ ] yes with this
barbell Brigade sweater they will barber
get calm it's so fast
lovely sweater that feels so good on my
skin it actually makes me want to work
out and sleep at the same time barbell
brigade
[Laughter]
all right for our last story there was
this epic battle between team black car
vs. team silver car on Twitter did you
guys hear oh dude the one a k-town right
yep the one in cages oh I did see it
don't lick yeah I'm gonna show you
yeah those fellas us the whole Twitter
bred by this girl she posted how these
two cars were in this like petty ass
battle trying to get this one parking
spot was hilarious I will show you a
compilation of her videos it was funny
so she said it started around six-30
petty levels so this is like 10 minutes
after it already started when she
started filming it so she said this
standoff is creating drama so they made
it to the 1 hour mark and then so this
car ends up pulling out oh my god oh my
god and so the black car pulls up but
this is after an hour already so silver
watch don't forgot the spot silver one
because she was doing a poll of like who
will get out of the car first because
they were sitting in their cars forever
yeah I would not get out damn they got
that much time sure are they scared you
know what's so k-town you know what's so
dumb about that [ __ ] well there's a
couple of things that's very
representative of how hard it is to find
public parking in k-town is la other
than k-town six years ago it was not
like that you asked a couple homie
homies to come over they could Park on
the street
everything's cool but because King Tom
became a spot number one essential to
everywhere DTLA little tokyo santa
monica you want to go anywhere kay towns
that spot and it was the cheapest place
to go a lot of people who were korean
just weren't lending there but it became
a hot spot for food and all this other
[ __ ] so I blew the [ __ ] up so it's
really hard to park at number two the
reason why this dump is because in that
hour you could have found some other
parking no in that hour and a half that
they were battling the [ __ ] up parking
spots open up in front of them but it
just got to the point where it's like
okay
yeah and so this [ __ ] just did they were
comfort each others not that we know I
think no I think I continue to read the
thread and like they were literally in
their car for like 30 minutes and silver
car started getting on his phone and
then she got out of the car and he just
left like black card never came out you
had nothing ever happened she ended up
writing a note to both cars saying like
I love your work thank you so much for
the entertainment for the entertainment
and as she created an email account
called like silver carve like we're
sorry over clover car versus black car
at gmail.com so she's like please email
me to tell your side of the story
hahaha but I definitely understand that
level of pettiness because I'm not on
that type of love oh does some [ __ ] work
you know when you have like a parking
spot yeah but then the person that's
trying to get into your spot like I'm
trying to find my [ __ ] and I start
honking the horn I'll stay in the car
for another 50 minutes just so they
don't get it yeah so there's the way
that she said that this could have got a
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that so there was this parking spot
and so black cart comes up and passes
the spot
Oh to Gomer very little part yeah but
that's when silver car came in I was
like nah and then started blocking them
in or blocking with black currant and
that's how that [ __ ] hole like started
they're very nice people because they
didn't get out the car or start cursing
each other out for power - you weren't
even honking at each other it was other
cars they built up traffic because they
were blocking up you both started going
around them petty is really high dude I
know I don't think I don't know how much
time I take on my [ __ ] just tank you
know yeah it feels really good though
when you win that petty battle like just
me sitting in that car for 15 minutes
and then are you leaving and I go but
you know what's crazy you know what's
better though and you can make your way
out of there and go to trips oh but it's
crazy cuz once you win that petty battle
right you're like slow clap right but
then after five minutes you're like [ __ ]
what did I do with my [ __ ] oh not me
I relish it a dude I'm like yes you have
yourself you know what's even better
when when that person waits and they get
[ __ ] man they leave and there's a car
behind them and I get out on like you
want the spot and I get how that I left
them
it feels like I held it as sneeze and I
wear at you become like the rest of the
day that purse is gonna be talking [ __ ]
about me and I'm just smiling that petty
dude I just don't like it when people
are mean to me you know for no reason
I'm just looking to get like for example
like I'm just trying to get like my GPS
coordinates you can just wait 30 seconds
but if you're gonna hold that [ __ ]
horn oh we could play that petty game
I'll cross my [ __ ] arms like this I
watched the [ __ ] bail channel like
this but yeah so then the girl was
posting all this to she she ended up
posting a video of herself dancing to
Tom Petty's Mary Jane's last band and
then in the next slide she circles Peggy
so she was just like this [ __ ] was
amazing did they ever email her so that
she's gotten a lot of fake like impostor
people oh and she also got an email from
a friend of that silver car that moved I
think it was a Honda and so they were
just saying like oh I realized that this
is taken in front of my spot and then my
friend was the one that actually drove
out whatever the help is just hilarious
like that just goes to show that you
know their parking here is horrendous
maybe we should get together because
this is really funny or whatever the
[ __ ]
but yeah there's emails her that's funny
dude but yeah I mean it's Freddie Vanna
Christy Teegan was like retweeting this
and she was just saying like black car
was just trying to parallel park and
silver cuts over have [ __ ] up silver
car was a mess
that's black our didn't signal maybe you
could even still meal if you see someone
backing up and you just like blocked
them you just be like [ __ ] that's rude
like why you know yeah yeah oh you could
just let that person Park and when they
leave use key their car dude I'm always
afraid of that and that's why I never
fight for parking because I don't want
my car getting keyed have you guys ever
keep the car it's very satisfying
oh it feels so funny I wanted to so bad
I'm like karma is a [ __ ] well that's
their Karma though you are karma you are
cop you are the car my name is karma
yeah I'm karma because they did bad
things so I'm karma so I I never thought
about it that's how I think about it any
feels really good if you're that much of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you just wait till you
leave and I think I mentioned it before
I used to this thing another teenager
where I would take long nails and you
just take it under the tire and you just
start knocking it in so when they roll
reverse out
it puts nails into the tires you know it
works like sometimes it doesn't wear it
happen all the time but it's a way for
you to get back at them without them
dying you don't want to kill them we
just want to make themself oh don't do
that kids that's terrible by the way but
I used to do that because I don't want
to slash their [ __ ] because attire
replacing the tire like on a Honda
Civics like what like 40 bucks of course
is that me scratching their pain and
they have to get a whole new paint job
right so it was a better way than just
doing that you did a nice thing yes yes
we appreciate you didn't kill him
I didn't cuz he's Karma I am Karma his
name Scott Irwin
[Music]